ρε μπορο να έχει τάρα ως τι έσθημα και να έχεις έναντι μια ομάδας του
πληθιμού που πάλι ο δημοκραός αερμό ένα αντιτήθέε σε κάθοτα αλομάτα το πληθισμού κα δικαιώματα
οπριαδίομ να κόφκουμε δικαματα οποιος συνέσηακανιώθει διότι ο γείτο να σου έτυχε να κακόστο και
πιπήρες μιανικό ναότι ούλι εγκακή που την συγκεκριμένη νομάδα πληθισμο ηλύσεις διαφορετικές ι ρεαλισμό του
τι στορια ναι στην κύπρόμποαέχουμε συγκεκριμέρο ν αριθμό πληθισμού δεν κα μπορείνε να σώματώσουμε το
οποιοόποιος έρτεναεν μπορεί να γίνει θεειόριο αλά θέλεορίο αι όου αλ λεφα διότι κι που
την άλλη πλευρα θρούμε να επιχειρήμαα του τύπου οιος ένας ρμα εδε γίνεται και το
ενός και του άλλού πρέπει ηθέση του δημοκραο ναγερού να είναι αυτή του ρεαλισμ και
τις αλήθειας πάντα πριθιγο από τες βουλευτικές κλίνει το ψηφοδελτε δμοκατικού συναγερμου σύντομα νομίζω αυτό
θα γίνει κάπου τοεύρσυμτ από το ευραλλά αντιλαμβάνομε πουπως ακούω και εγώ νένα σχολούμενας πότιδιατερος
με τολμεμ τις συζήση προσώπο και τα λιβά αλλά νταξις μετέέχο στάση λέγα όργανα με
τρόπο που ξέρω ότι είμαστε κοντά η πληροφόράρχει υπάρχειρκει τον ενδιαφέρω σε όλε τες επάρχει
θανετε που αόσαοίδι και να υπάρχει διαφέρομνα σε ρωήσω η θυμολογία θέλει ότι πολύ σύντομα
εντο του καλοκαιριού να υπάρξει ένα σχηματισμός ότι φτάνει σε δν αν επίπεδο ο πρόεδρος
που θέλει να φρεσκάρει την ομάδα να αν δούμε μιχάλη μου πάλε στελέχει του κόμματος
τους μογανικού συναγερμού στελέχει τα οποία εγνωστήσει ναγερμή και ένα προσπεσί να βάλεται να βέτο
να τους πείτε όπα να που γάμνεται θα πάτε ναι αινα σουποθησίάμου δεν εντουσιορκούμο τοτο
θέμα ηλικρινά δδιεναι ναι θέμα μπο μπορώ να